a moment ago Jackie you said that
finding financing for films is difficult
yeah let's take your your own record how
many feature films have you made I think
it's 1414 Wow okay so since do you mind
telling me the year yeah I think while
my first feature was in 1991 okay so
that's that that movie America's
deadliest home video we actually just
got rereleased on video a couple of
months ago because it's now considered
sort of the grandfather of found footage
movies I that my first week my first
feature was a sort of this formal
exercise where I had to I it was it was
a typical I don't know if we talked
about this but it was it was interesting
circumstance where I had come to LA I
couldn't get a job pouring coffee or
making Xeroxes or anything and I met a
guy was introduced to a guy who was from
Wisconsin who said hey I have seven
thousand dollars on credit cards I want
to make a movie in in Racine Wisconsin
where I'm from my dad is used to be the
sheriff there so we can like shoot guns
and blow stuff up and we don't have to
get permits or anything and I need
someone to write and direct a movie and
he also said also i'm going to be in it
because I'm he's producing and acting
which is I now a fairly classic way for
an actor who has any kind of resources
to make sure he gets a plum role is to
produce the movie so that he doesn't
have to worry about getting cast and
that comes with it and he couldn't pay
me anything but he said he could he
would finance what effectively my first
feature and I was like yeah of
course i'll do that i'll do it and it
had to be an exploitation movie because
this was still at the you know the
beginning of the 90s tail end of the 80s
there was still a lot of exploitation
movies being sold on video shows
low-budget exploitation so it had to
have sex and had to have violins and had
a certain body count all those things
that are fairly standard for that but i
could write any story i wanted and the
only caveat was that it had to be shot
on video there was not enough money to
shoot it on film it had to be shot on
and at that time it was 30 frames per
second video there wasn't any 20
or P nothing it was it was ugly and I
had just come from my NYU film school
days making this lush black and white
rich you know gothic eraser you know was
like this the image was everything and
now I got to shoot my first feature on
video so I wrestled with it I was like
I'm really unhappy with this is this is
going to look like a porn or it's going
to look it's not going to look like good
at all and so I came upon this idea of
what if I made the look of the video an
inherent part of the story and so I came
up with this idea of a home video
enthusiast and this was the time when
the camcorder and america's funniest
home videos and all that was just coming
into bloom what about a camcorder
enthusiasts who accidentally shoots a
crime in progress and the gang that's
committing the crime drafts him into
their gang and forces him to document
their crime spree and every shot every
edit edit would be dictated when the
camera was on or when it was off or when
the battery died or if the camera all
that all the sort of tenants of found
footage grammar what you see in
everything I was sort of i wasn't
inventing it because there had been a
couple of different filmmakers who had
tried it but i was trying to make an
exploitation movie in a way that
justified its look and it turned out to
be one of a few of the first ones in
that genre so so i know it's a long
digression but but that that film
America's deadliest home video which is
a play on obviously the show was my
first feature and that start Danny
Bonaduce from the old Partridge Family
he was the first yeah radio host and a
radio host to yeah yeah so he was the he
plays the home video enthusiast who gets
abducted oh that's perfect yeah and
Melora Walters who oh yeah showed up in
paul thomas anderson's movies Magnolia
and boogie nights she had been in my nyu
thesis film so I drafted her you know
but this was before she was doing those
homes obviously and you know and it was
like classic first feature it was made
for a few thousand dollars on credit
cards and so forth but then it sort of
got lost for years and you know when the
blair witch project came out everyone
was like this is brand new and exciting
how it's kind of like
okay I ten years ago I you know I
actually did something like this and now
it's been 25 years so it's it's
resurfaced and camp motion pictures
which is a DVD label just rereleased it
so so it's cool was X it was exciting to
have the film sort of rediscovered and
how was it rediscovered like did you get
a phone call or yeah one day what
happened was is I was sort of you know
from time to time I'm kind of like I'm
I'm one of those filming I think all
filmmakers are so self-critical that you
don't voluntarily look at your old
movies and see you know watch them
because all you're going to see is your
mistakes but I got contacted by a guy
who was a real fan of this guy Josh
Schaefer who writes this some VHS
centric fanzine or magazine called lunch
meat which is all about VHS culture
which has now become very popular in the
last few years just like vinyl to Gahan
this kind of like nostalgic almost
fetishistic like you know the people
worship at the altar of vinyl VHS funny
enough has become Wow has become that
and he was showing America's deadliest
home video not enough but he didn't
really get any permission but he was
screening it at different sort of small
fee movie theaters and stuff and I got
wind of this and he I said why is this
movie skies in my movie screening in New
York at this weird underground club so I
contacted him and he said oh I'm an
enormous fan and I think this movie
needs to be seen and he ended up
becoming a champion or the champion and
getting it distributed and he put us in
contact or he contacted the distributor
and after a few years this finally came
out so so it was very cool it was cool
because it like I was I was
understandably or maybe not
understandably but not bitter but just
upset that that the timing was wrong for
that in other words when the movie came
out in 91 it was a novelty and I got
some attention but it wasn't like it
didn't do with that that magical thing
that all filmmakers want they want their
first feature to be Sex Lies and
videotape or reservoir dogs all sudden
opens up these you know these gold gates
open and you
up in and you don't have ever have a
worry you know like about access anyway
but and it didn't do that but then the
blair witch project was you know ten
years later was touted for its
innovative you know design and this
first person sort of through the camera
point of view thing when and I again I
wasn't the first person who ever did
this I mean there were other filmmakers
who explored this and I was inspired by
them there was a film called 84 Charlie
mobic I don't know if you remember this
which was a film in the 80s that was a
Vietnam War movie but all from the point
of view of a combat cameraman Wow it was
fascinating it was low-budget
independent movie and it was i believe
the filmmaker had been a combat
cameraman or he was in the war and it
was all about this particular taking on
this particular point of view of the war
from the point of view of a combat
cameraman so it had this very
documentary quality to it and that's how
it was staged you know sean and so that
was an influence and also first person
POV movies going all the way back to
like there was movie the lady in the
lake which which robert montgomery made
in 1947 which is an apt ation of the
Raymond Chandler book is entirely the
whole movie is entirely from the point
of view of Philip Marlowe like you every
shot is your you in fact that's how they
marketed it it was like you will solve
the Quran you will kiss the girl so
everything was shot from this very
subjective so those things influence me
and I was able to kind of put that
rearrange that into a crime thriller but
anyway it's been it's been cool to see
it kind of come out
you